hello in this video I'll talk about
transcription in eukaryotes in order to
make the metabolic demand of a cell cell
need to produce enzymes and several
other protein molecules and the
instruction to create that protein
molecules or truck or to give rise to
that proteins are inside the DNA now
this messages inside the DNA are decoded
by specific decoders such that it
produced the genetic blueprint which is
the mRNA and that happens in a process
known as transcription in eukaryotes we
cannot simply imagine transcription like
whatever it is depicted here because I
mean this kind of situation is pretty
incorrect because in eukaryotes there is
the scenario is totally different and
let's just talk about the transcription
initiation in eukaryote then we can
appreciate that why the situations in
eukaryotic transcription is very
different from a prokaryotic
transcription in eukaryotes
the gene is not only DNA is like in
bacteria
gene is organized in chromatin already
you have histones associated with this
DNA and the DNA is wrapped around this
histone so there is a steric issue as
well in order for the transcript in
order for the transcription factors the
RNA polymerase to bind to the specific
promoter region it is pretty difficult
for that because let's say there is a
gene which is at least 1 KB in length
and let's say a nucleosome typically
spans about 200 base pairs so at least a
gene would comprise of 5 nucleotides and
in this whole span need to be covered by
RNA polymerase so the movement of the
polymer is the binding of the RNA
polymerase is not so easy in eukaryotes
definitely in case of cold histone
octamer we can understand that how
compactly it is this packaging happens
so in this
the RNA polymerase can only bind if the
DNA wrapped around the histone octamer
is loosened up question comes that how
the DNA wrapped around the core histone
octamers could be loosened up in inside
a chromatin and this kind of loosening
up or accessibility could be achieved by
specific enzymes known as histone
modifiers which modifies the histone
make them slide away or replace one
histone with histone variants there
other which are called as nucleosome
remodelling complex nucleosome
remodeling complex remodel the landscape
of the chromatin making some time it
more accessible for some transcription
factor or RNA polymerase or some time
making it more in excess able so
nucleosome remodeling factors are very
important thing for eukaryotic
transcription itself after that we have
to understand itself the enzyme which
transcribes is way more complex in case
of eukaryotes because in prokaryotes we
have only one type of RNA polymerase
whereas in eukaryotes we have at least
three type of RNA polymerase and the RNA
polymerase 2 is the key enzyme which
transcribed mRNAs so in this video we
would be focusing on paul 2 rather than
the other ones
and we would be talking about the
mechanism of pol ii based transcription
of mRNAs now this mRNA this polymer is 2
and general transcription factor create
a huge complex on the chromatin known as
initiation complex the initiative and
here is the comparison between the
prokaryotic RNA polymerase versus a
eukaryotic RNA polymerase definitely
eukaryotic organisms are complex than
prokaryote so eukaryotic RNA polymerases
comprising at least 12 to 15 subunits
where as prokaryotic RNA polymerase only
have 5 subunits but there is a dramatic
similarity between prokaryotic and
eukaryotic trunk RNA polymerase in
prokaryote we have earlier seen that the
active zone was comprising of beta - and
beta subunit and here in the eukaryotic
RNA polymerase as well the active zone
is comprising of RB p1 and RB p2 which
are structurally pretty similar to
beater - and beta subunit also there is
a there are two subunits are will be 11
and R will be 3 which are quite similar
to alpha 1 and alpha 2
unlike prokaryotic polymerase there is
no Sigma factor present in case of
eukaryotic polymerase then how does the
promoter recognition happens let's just
look at it so there is a huge complex
and in this complex the part of these
complex are generalized transcription
factors generally the generalized
transcription factors fall under TF 2
family one of the most important player
of that is tf2d tf2d has two parts one
is called data box binding protein and
another is called deaf apart from TF to
t TF 280 f2f tf2b and tf2h are important
other transcription factors generalized
transcription factors which help in
several aspects of the initiation and
the promoter escape now tf2d has the
main subunit which is known as Tata box
binding protein or TB B which binds to a
consensus Tata box sequence in the
promoter
unlike other DNA binding proteins tbp
has an unusual property first of all tbp
is not a helix it instant it's a bitter
plated sheet now TPP bind to the top box
and bind in in the major in the minor
groove and that is unusual because other
DNA binding protein binds to the DNA in
a metric roof and once TPP binds it
bends the DNA around 80 degrees and that
makes the chromatin more accessible for
the
scription to start now in the first step
of elongation the RNA polymers need to
escape from the promoter and starts is
journey along the gene now definitely
this promoter escaped the license for
promoter escape is given by one of the
generalized transcription factor known
as tf2h tf2h has dual activity helices
activity which helps to open the DNA in
the near vicinity and also it has a
kinase activity which phosphorylates a
c-terminal domain of rbp one subunit and
the c-terminal domain has a peptide
repeat containing several serine
residues and this tf2h phosphorylates at
that serine residues once tf2h phosphor
eyelets in the serine residues the RNA
polymerase the eukaryotic RNA polymerase
polymerase is licensed to escape the
promoter and move forward to transcribe
the gene now while it is transcribing
the gene after moving twenty to
twenty-five nucleotides all other
generalised transcription factors fall
off from this complex only TF to f
while the drugs while the polymerase is
traversing its way throughout the genes
length now the elongation chemistry is
pretty similar to that of prokaryote so
the RNA polymerase moving a 3 prime to 5
prime 5 prime to 3 prime direction and
at the same time the structure the
internal structure is pretty similar so
there is a DNA entry site that is
comprised by rb1 and rb2 subunit there
is a ntp entry site and also there is a
site for exiting a tunnel which is a
site for exiting the mRNA which is
parallel to the c-terminal domain and it
has a deep meaning to it which i would
be discussing the basic chemistry is
again metal ion catalyzed catalysis
it requires the RNA polymerase requires
magnesium based catalyst
and nucleophilic attack from the age
group of a NTP to a strand of growing
strand so as a result a polymerization
reaction could happen new phosphodiester
bond could form now apart from
interactions in the water the elongation
rate could be regulated by other
transcription factors acting in acting
in a binding in a distant location other
than the promoter other than the
promoter there are sequences known as
enhancer may be located several base
pair several thousand base pairs
upstream or downstream here it is shown
only upstream now these enhancers could
bind to specialized transcription
factors and by a DNA looping mechanism
it can interact with co-activator which
can further bridge the interaction with
the core promoter elements and thereby
increasing the rate of transcription or
increase the rate or fidelity by which
the RNA polymerase would escape the
promoter and run along the gene length
to transcribe the gene apart from that
there are several factors which help in
this elongation one of such factor is
known as PT FB or transcription
elongation factor B pit FB phosphorylate
several residues on the c-terminal
domain and first of all it helps in
promoter escape otherwise it helps in to
enhance the rate of transcription and
binding of several other modification
enzymes we have to understand basic
post-transcriptional modifications in
these mRNAs are happening simultaneously
while the RNA polymerase is moving along
the chain length and transcribing the
mRNA not only this kind of specific
elongation factors or tf2h can modify
CTD this modified CTD is a platform for
many interactions many proteins many
modification MRR any modification
enzymes such as
splicing enzymes such as capping enzymes
bind to this phosphorylated L and now
this phosphorylated tail is pretty
parallel to the newly growing mRNA newly
growing mRNA which is exiting from the
tunnel of the RA eukaryotic RNA
polymerase
now these capping enzyme can
simultaneously create modifications even
when there there is transcription
happening so thus eukaryotic RNA
polymerase has an incredible capability
of doing multitasking simultaneous post
processing with the transcription now
after that comes termination now the
termination in eukaryotes it's not to
well work out so there is clearly no
termination sequence as in prokaryotes
then how the termination happens so it
turns out that the RNA polymerase even
after transcribing the gene to the full
length still progresses several base
pairs but you know there is a
adenylation site known as a a UA a so
this site is recognized by several
cleavage factors known as cpsf and cstf
these cleavage factors bind to the
specific site cleave the mRNA from there
once it cleave people hypothesize and
there are experimental evidences for
that there are several rnase like rat
one eats the RNA out from that and
releases the RNA polymerase definitely
there are alternative hypothesis
hypothesis exist in the field but this
is one of the most established one of
eukaryotic transcription termination so
this concludes my video on eukaryotic
transcription and this was an overview
if you liked my video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you